motivation you get to learn to exist
without it what do you think most people
get wrong about motivation they think
that maybe once I get it I'm gonna hold
on to it and a lot of times you have to
learn to perform without motivation you
have to learn perform without purpose
and that's what people think they think
I need to have this motivation to work
out to study to be better so if they
don't have it they just don't do it and
that's where you fail you have to learn
to train your mind well beyond
motivation if you have motivation that's
great that's some can lean to the fire
all it takes is a little bit of spark
you can burn the whole forced up
motivation you have to learn to exist
without it you have to be your best self
and your least motivated and that's the
tricky part about all that motivation is
just a word you have to have these
different things in your mind on where
you want to go and know that motivation
is not going to get me there